Bernard Tapie quel est votre image de
marque mauvaise et votre argent ça peut
séduire beaucoup plus que mon charme
beaucoup plus alors ça se fait pas
l'ombre c'est la vraie star des années
c'est l'histoire d'un businessman à qui
tout réussi
Bernard Tapie est beau riche et
séduisant
[Musique]
chef d'entreprise animateur télé patron
de l'OM tapis est une machine à gagner
mais tout va changer pour lui le jour où
il va entrer en politique
[Musique]
vous êtes à hâbleur vous êtes un
Tartarin un bluffeur voilà la vérité
devenu ministre de Pierre Bérégovoy
tapis et soupçonné de piller les caisses
de l'État avec l'aide du pouvoir
Bernard Tapie est dans mon gouvernement
je considère qu'il est honnête je lui
fais confiance
depuis que tapis est proche du pouvoir
les scandales politiques aux financiers
éclatent les mises en examen
s'enchaînent
une réaction s'il vous plaît
[Musique]
nous sommes là parce que on vient de
vous attribuer 400 millions d'euros
d'argent public je souhaite pas de
porter un seul jour un nom qui devient
une injure publique c'est comme si je
m'appelais pourri ordure ma
grande récompense dans cette affaire
c'est qu'aujourd'hui il est seul la
gauche l'abandonné il a droite
l'abandonner
nous allons vous raconter les péripéties
d'un flambeur qui a été flambée
l'histoire d'un manipulateur au combien
manipulé qui veut abattre Bernard Tapie
tout le monde vous trouverez personne
pour le défendre
[Musique]
je sais pas faire ça c'est un jeu
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est l'une de ces toutes premières
apparitions à la télévision Bernard
Tapie a 40 ans et il est un homme
d'affaires brillant qui a bâti en un
temps record une fortune colossale
partie de rien ce fils d'ouvrier de la
banlieue parisienne et fier d'afficher
son impressionnante réussite dans cette
émission d'Antenne 2 au titre un brin
tapageur mais qui annonce clairement la
couleur
avec le concours de Bernard Tapie
président du Groupe Bernard Tapie
ce faiseur de fric a déjà tout compris à
la télé
en acceptant d'être filmé dans son
intimité il cultive une image de chefs
d'entreprise moderne dynamique un patron
libéral sans aucun tabou
rien de plus redoutable de vivre dans un
système capitaliste avec des gens qui ne
le sont pas or l'unité de mesure d'un
système capitaliste c'est l'argent alors
pour moi mon unité de mesure est en
argent
j'entreprends mes affaires et je l'ai
fait entreprendre par tout ce que ceux
qui m'entourent avec une volonté férose
de gagner beaucoup beaucoup d'argent
Bernard Tapie est l'un des premiers en
France a parlé de manière aussi
décomplexée des vertus de l'argent
il faut dire que les Français viennent
délire deux ans plus tôt François
Mitterrand un président socialiste pour
qui l'argent est le capitalisme sont si
l'on en croit ses discours des ennemis à
abattre
la société capitaliste celui-là je le
dis il ne peut pas être adhérent du
parti socialiste
[Musique]
autant dire que tapis et son jet privé
font quelque peu mauvais genre dans
cette France en pleine crise économique
mais l'homme d'affaires assume tout et
imprime son style avec un franc-parler
inhabituel à la télévision
en fait je crois que les médiocres
notamment rabaissant la performance des
autres c'est pas nouveau je crois que
objectivement de faire une confidence la
vie des médiocres complètement égale
parce que au fond de moi je crois
vraiment que je les emmène tapis a
toujours sécrété leur vie à la jalousie
parce qu'il était beau à mourir parce
que il était riche parce que il était
aimé les Français et c'est si espèce de
rancoeur accumulées qui criera le
phénomène tapis
un phénomène qui fait polémique car
tapis s'enrichit en rachetant des
sociétés au bord du dépôt de bilan sur
les conseils de son avocat et amis
Jean-Louis Borloo
à l'époque de nombreux entrepreneurs au
bord du gouffre consultent le duo tapis
Borlo pour tenter de sauver leur
entreprise de la faillite
et l'homme d'affaires a un flair
infaillible pour miser sur celle qui
vont lui rapporter très vite beaucoup
d'argent
cette année 1983 par exemple tapis
rachète la petite entreprise look qui
fabrique des skis pour un petit franc
symbolique
cinq ans plus tard il réussit à la
revendre un joli pactole de 40 millions
d'euros au milieu des années 80 tapis
est à la tête d'une quarantaine
d'entreprises et réalise un chiffre
d'affaires juteux de 800 millions
d'euros ils avaient mis au point un
système qui leur permettait de racheter
des boîtes en difficulté ensuite il
dégraissait et ensuite il revendait au
meilleur prix une fois qu'il avait fait
le nettoyage et c'est comme ça que il a
fait une fortune colossale parce qu'à
l'époque il sautait vraiment sur tout ce
qui bouge c'est un désosseur c'est un
vautour
il reprend à la casse des entreprises
pour les désosser
malgré des méthodes contestables
l'entrepreneur est à l'époque un modèle
de réussite qui donne des conférences un
peu partout en France comme dans cette
école de commerce ou avec son ami Borlo
il livre aux étudiants les clés du
succès trois qualités imaginatif vendeur
moneur
quel type de course je donnerais vous
serez tellement obligé de négocier tout
le temps que ce soit avec vos
fournisseurs et vos concurrents à votre
personnel avec vos banquiers avec votre
femme enfin ou avec votre mari vous
serez tellement obligé de négocier je
vous apprendrai avant chaque fois il
remplit la salle il arrive avec son
avion à Limoges ou à Angoulême on fait
son show les gens sont là se précipitent
sur lui en disant enfin quelqu'un qui
nous parle de l'entreprise de façon
décomplexée etc et ça va être les
émissions ambition et les émissions
ambitions qui faisaient en prime time
plus de 30% c'était on parlait
d'économie à 8h30 à façon de tapis une
espèce de chaux absolument incroyable
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
Bernard Tapie et le patron le plus
médiatisé de France TF1 le choisit tout
naturellement pour animer la première
émission entièrement dédiée à
l'entreprise et au business
[Musique]
et comme s'il avait fait ça toute sa vie
l'homme d'affaires crève l'écran un
Français sur trois interrogé dit
j'aimerais entreprendre et pourtant un
sur 1000 seulement entreprendre mon
ambition c'est qu'il y en ait plus
seulement un sur 1000 qui est en ville
entreprendre c'est qu'il y en ait 5
c'est qu'il y en ait 10 c'est qu'il y en
aient 100 et qu'en fin parce qu'on est
le pays le plus génial on devienne aussi
le pays leader
l'économie à la sauce Tapie fait un
carton et pas seulement auprès de la
ménagère de TF1
le lendemain invité sur le plateau
d'Yves Mourousi le président de la
République lui-même avoue être tombé
sous le charme de l'homme d'affaires
il faut il faut s'appeler Coluche tapis
Delon récemment dans le Figaro Magazine
XYZ pour faire passer des vibrations que
l'on attend des politiques je le dis
peut-être moins bien
mais ma conviction rencontre celle de
tapis et de bien d'autres et j'admire
ceux qui en sont capables et dans la
mesure de mes moyens avec les moyens
aussi de ma fonction vraiment je
m'efforce de les aider Mitterrand sent
très bien que un personnage comme ça
peut être un atout pour réconcilier la
gauche et l'argent la gauche et
l'entreprise
l'ouverture vers le capitalisme entre
guillemets je pense que Mitterrand a eu
l'intuition de se dire c'est un homme
nouveau en politique et ça nous
apportera une forme de fraîcheur
tapis à taper dans l'oeil du président
et cela tombe bien car l'homme
d'affaires a très envie de se frotter à
la politique
Julie ne fait pas de politique Bernard
ce sont des piradas ils vont te dévorer
laisse ça de côté tu as tout pour
réussir dans la vie tu fais pour faire
des affaires il m'a dit oui mais j'ai
connu le business
j'ai connu largeur je veux connaître ce
pouvoir de la de la politique et puis je
veux faire du bien aux Français
quelques mois plus tard le businessman
et le président vont finir par se
rencontrer grâce aux efforts d'une
connaissance commune le publicitaire
Jacques Séguéla l'entourage de François
Mitans ne voulait pas qu'il le voit
particulier à tali qui nous disait ne
pas y aller et puis tout le monde autour
de lui qui disait mais attention on
fréquente pas un Bernard Tapie il faut
s'écarter de tout ça c'est que c'était
beaucoup François mitter
Jacques Séguéla organise un déjeuner
chez lui à Neuilly-sur-Seine et il
assiste au grand numéro de charme de
tapis sur le président
il y a eu trois heures d'une rencontre
entre deux personnages entre deux forces
de la nature et de l'esprit qui ont
échangé comme ça et c'est là où j'ai vu
la fascination de Mitterrand qui lui a
fait comme ils savaient le faire une
cour
extraordinaire et qu'il a subjugué à
tout jamais et qui lui a dit vous êtes
fait pour la politique et on se retrouve
en 1987 tapis est donc dans les petits
papiers du président de la République
il souhaite entrer en politique mais il
n'a pas encore choisi son camp il attend
quel lieu la prochaine élection
présidentielle dans quelques mois
François Mitterrand et candidat à sa
propre succession mais un homme à droite
est capable de le battre c'est son
premier ministre Jacques Chirac tapis va
se plier en quatre pour tenter de le
séduire lui aussi
[Musique]
de mes numéros
ces images dans mon cœur dans ma vie
tout est un match aujourd'hui
Bernard Tapie anime l'émission de
variétés match 2000 sur TF1 il a invité
le candidat à la présidentielle Jacques
Chirac et pour l'accueillir il n'hésite
pas à en faire des tonnes
la personnalité que je vais rejoindre
maintenant est une grande star cette
grande star cette grande vedette et oui
devinez qui est-ce
[Applaudissements]
et oui c'est pas Madonna non mais c'est
notre premier ministre
un peu de calme
l'avantage avec les hommes politiques
c'est de l'ambiance vous voyez à 8 mois
de la présidentielle Bernard Tapie offre
une vitrine médiatique exceptionnelle
aux candidat du RPR vous savez c'est
quand surtout à tous ceux qui créent et
dans tous les domaines c'est grâce à
ceux qui font Ariane je viens de faire
48000 km en 30 000 km en 37 heures grâce
à ceux qui ont fait Concorde c'est à ces
hommes là que l'on doit que la France
soit un grand pays
je profite que vous soyez là pour vous
dire que très souvent trop souvent
droite ou gauche les hommes politiques
sont pas jugés par les Français à la
valeur que la leur et je le dis parce
que je le pense et au nom de
l'intégralité des gens qui pensent comme
moi moi je vous tire un coup de chapeau
à tous et bien on remercie notre premier
ministre monsieur Jacques Chirac qui a
fait les milliers de kilomètres pour
être présents ce soir et pour marquer il
était pas indifférent aux choses de
notre existence
l'invitation de Jacques Chirac peut
paraître anodine mais à quelques mois
des élections elle n'est pas dénuée chez
Bernard Tapie de tout arrière pensée
politique
il pense qu'il va être élu et qu'il faut
toujours être du côté du manche pour
arranger ses affaires pour moi c'est
aussi simple que cela vous savez c'est
pas forcément un homme extrêmement
complexe Bernard Tapie de ce point de
vue là et c'est là on voit
la solidité des convictions politiques
de Bernard Tapie sa seule conviction
politique c'est d'être tapiste là où
sont mes intérêts là je vais aller
politiquement il a un culot d'enfer et
donc personne n'imagine la duplicité et
sa capacité de mensonge il a été
quand ça l'arrangeait à gauche après si
ça l'arrange il est à droite mais il est
bourré de talent et tout le monde veut
le connaître
l'homme d'affaires a du talent on a rien
de temps il est parvenu à charmer à
gauche et à droite les deux favoris de
l'élection présidentielle
[Musique]
il ne reste plus qu'à attendre que soit
désigné le vainqueur
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
François Mitterrand vient d'être réélu
selon l'estimation bulbea avec 53,9 %
des voix le 8 mai 1988 Mitterrand est
largement réélu face à Jacques Chirac
tapis va entrer en politique à gauche
dans le camp socialiste
et cela tombe à pic pour le président
qui après sept ans au pouvoir a besoin
d'ouvrir le parti à des hommes neufs et
populaires Mitterrand est amusé par ce
profil il a pas de profil comme ça en
stock il a pas ce personnage un peu
libéral
truculent et qui ose tout et cette
espèce de culot fascide Mitterrand c'est
vrai que tapis à ce moment-là
incarne non seulement l'argent mais
l'argent financier incarne la
spéculation incarne les dérèglements
voilà tapis à une tête de dérèglement
financier mais ça ça ne fait pas peur du
tout à François Mitterrand il se dit
mais immédiatement ça va intriguer ça va
déranger mes adversaires ça va
m'apporter quelque chose
un mois seulement après la
présidentielle les Français doivent
retourner aux urnes pour élire leur
députés cette fois-ci
[Musique]
Mitterrand à la une occasion rêvée de
lancer tapis en politique et il choisit
pour lui Marseille
Marseille car ici l'homme d'affaires est
presque un dieu vivant
deux ans plus tôt il vient de reprendre
l'OM le mythique club de foot Marseille
et il est en train de le faire renaître
de ses cendres la popularité de tapis à
Marseille devrait l'aider à remporter
une élection compliquée
car Mitterrand mise beaucoup sur lui
pour affronter ici un adversaire coriace
Jean-Marie Le Pen également candidat à
Marseille
son parti le Front National a atteint
dans cette région le score historique de
26% à la présidentielle et la gauche n'a
pas encore trouvé le moyen de lui barrer
la route il faut l'abattre à tout prix
sera bien compte qu'il y a un danger du
Front national qui se précise et il
demande à tapis j'ai besoin que vous
m'aidiez je vous demande de vous
présenter en politique à Marseille pour
lutter contre le Front National et il me
dit qu'est-ce que tu en penses toi je
lui dis mais je pense que tu vas le
faire
je pense que si mitterrandt le demande
bien sûr que tu vas le faire rien ne
pourra t'en empêcher tu en meurt d'envie
et tu vas le faire il peut être
médiatiquement celui qui va terrasser le
Pen celui qui va faire rempart de son
corps pour empêcher le peine de se faire
élire à Marseille et en même temps faire
une entrée en politique très facile
tapis se présente donc au législatives
persuadée d'avoir toutes les cartes en
main
il va vite se rendre compte qu'en
politique il n'est pas du tout le maître
du jeu
pour l'heure ils font cette baissée
étant une opération séduction auprès de
son adversaire Jean-Marie Le Pen je le
rappelle d'un coup de téléphone qui m'a
donné
il m'a dit Jean-Marie c'est Bernard
qui a des Bernard Tapie il faudrait
qu'on se voit alors il faut écouter on
se verra plutôt entre les deux tours ça
serait plus raisonnable voilà et puis ça
s'arrête là
il m'a appelé il m'avait jamais vu de sa
vie mais
pas de problème quoi c'est Bernard
qu'est-ce qu'il voulait
je ne sais pas
établir une relation apparemment
cordiale avec un
candidat du Front national ou le
président du Front national
qui veut la fin veulent les moyens
pour gagner tapis serait-il prêt à
négocier avec Jean-Marie Le Pen il n'en
aura de toute façon pas l'occasion car
les socialistes marseillais ont manœuvré
pour empêcher ce face-à-face tapis se
fait rouler en fait par les socialistes
marseillais tapis se lance en politique
en étant persuadé qu'il va lui-même
affronter Jean-Marie Le Pen et en fait
les socialistes locaux ont très bien
compris que tapis est là pour leur voler
la vedette et probablement pour se
préparer derrière à une campagne
municipale et à devenir une espèce de
leader de la gauche évidemment les
socialistes marseillais ne veulent pas
de cette de cette intrus dans leur jeu
et donc ils vont lui monter un coup et
en réalité ils vont l'envoyer dans une
autre circonscription
tapine affrontera donc pas Jean-Marie Le
Pen et sera catapulté dans une autre
circonscription de Marseille face à
guitessier un candidat de droit très
difficile à battre
furieux tapis contact le patron du PS
local Michel peset tapis m'appelle à
l'époque
en disant tout de moi c'est Le Pen qui
m'intéresse je n'en doute pas mais moi
pas du tout donc si vous allez chez
Tessier ça va si vous n'allez pas été si
je ne suis nullement demandeur à votre
venue dans les Bouches-du-Rhône vous
voyez arriver gros comme un soleil
l'idée de la candidature à la mairie de
Marseille bon c'était ça
tapis s'est fait avoir comme un bleu par
son propre camp mais il ne lâche rien et
il va tout faire pour battre le très
coriace gui Tessier
[Musique]
électorale de sa vie mais tapis
appliquent les recettes qui ont fait son
succès dans les affaires
Babou séduction et promesse de lendemain
qui chantent
quand je dis il y aura plus un jeune
chômeur sans formation ici dans moins de
3 ans je l'écrire parce que je vais le
faire si c'est ça qui vole je vais
l'écrire et je vais m'y engager par
exemple les autres ils passent leur
temps à dire aimons-nous les uns les
autres il faut reculer il parle il
bavasse alors ça ici il y en a des
parleurs il n'avait pas de code il était
gonflé solide et courageux c'était une
façon de faire de la politique était une
façon physique de faire la politique sur
le terrain il est aussi bon que dans le
foot que quand elle est je veux dire ça
personne ne lui a appris comment il faut
se comporter pendant une campagne
électorale mais la partie est loin
d'être gagnée pour tapis diteriez le
candidat de droite qu'il affronte ne se
laisse pas du tout impressionner par le
show médiatique de celui qu'il surnomme
le Parisien
[Musique]
le milliardaire
parisiennes le milliardaire parisien
tapis a un gros point faible il n'est
pas marseillais alors pour séduire les
électeurs il décide de faire toute sa
campagne sur un thème très médiatique
lutter contre le Front National et
contre Jean-Marie Le Pen qui n'est
pourtant pas candidat face à lui
allez salut
[Musique]
et à bientôt
il faut effectivement battre le Front
national
tapis série Jean symbole de la lutte
anti Le Pen et l'effet est immédiat la
France entière se délecte du duel entre
les deux hommes pourquoi vous n'avez pas
accepté de rencontrer benart Tapie vous
fait peur
si j'ose dire n'est-ce pas monsieur
tapis est un marginal de la politique un
avis de publicité y compris à l'occasion
des élections d'entreprises en politique
c'est utile
en général sur les débris des autres
entreprises et sur le licenciement
massif des travailleurs dans les
entreprises qui le rachète généralement
pour un franc à la case et la raison
pour laquelle vous ne voulez
définitivement pas le rencontrer à la
télévision
ma circonscription et puis nous sommes
millionnaires l'un et l'autre moi en
vrai et lui en dollars nous ne sommes
pas encore une fois dans sur la même
longueur d'onde
tapis a bien compris la puissance
médiatique de cet affrontement est
toujours devant les caméras il joue la
surenchère en accusant TF1 de faire de
la publicité à Jean-Marie Le Pen
[Musique]
serv
il a un bic comme ça il est plein de
sous plein de sous tu vois alors la une
j'ai proposé un débat face à face il a
dit non alors à ce moment-là ça
intéresse les Françaises face à face
alors continuez à lui servir la soupe
toute façon on va quand même l'éjecter
de Marseille sa comédien quand au moment
où il était le grand adversaire du Front
national quand il nous croisait au
Parlement européen dans les couloirs il
ne faisait un clin d'oeil bon
c'est tarifiant c'est un personnage je
le reconnais
talentueux dans ses prestations mais
voilà moi qu'on puisse dire c'est pas
très sérieux en politique
et pourtant le grand numéro de tapis
fonctionne
en combattant le Front national l'homme
d'affaires se pose en sauveur de
Marseille et les Marseillais en
redemande
dans sa circonscription il a désormais
de bonnes chances de battre son
adversaire guités
[Musique]
Bernard Tapie un point c'est tout
le 12 juin 1988 c'est le soir du
deuxième tour
à 20h les premiers dépouillement sont
très encourageants pour Bernard Tapie
qui se voit déjà élu député face à
guitessier
à sa permanence on fête déjà l'événement
[Musique]
Bernard Tapie et son épouse Dominique
savoure le moment et à 20h30 le candidat
rejoint le plateau d'Antenne 2 pour
faire une déclaration
tapis et tout sourire certains d'avoir
battu guités mais pendant le trajet la
situation a basculé
S
la mauvaise nouvelle je lui dis t'a pas
gagné tu as perdu Laurent appelle la
permanence
il y a un résultat qui donne 99 fois de
plus à Teyssier et nos calculs c'est 300
voix de plus et ici on a appelé chez tes
siècles d'essayer de 10 qu'il a 99 watts
de bus que toi il est allé sur le
plateau et rien ne pouvait laisser
deviner la rage dans laquelle il était
et la déception personnelle aussi qui
était la sienne Bernard Tapie étant
direct avec nous à l'autre bout de
Marseille à l'hôtel Sofitel vous nous
entendez on attendait votre réaction
tout à l'heure à 20h au résultat qu'on
donnait vous êtes déçu j'imagine ben oui
je suis d'autant plus déçu que il y a
une heure on m'annonçait vainqueur avec
277 voies d'avance et puis lorsque tout
toutes les serviettes se sont ramassées
pour aller au bureau central on est on
est revenu avec 80 de retard c'est la
dernière chose à laquelle je m'attendais
enfin je me suis effectivement heurté
pendant toute cette campagne un métier
nouveau
quelques heures plus tard c'est officiel
tapis perd l'élection de 83 voies à
peine la droite marseillaise exulte à
l'image du député Jean-Claude Gaudin qui
trouve un malin plaisir ce soir-là à
moucher en direct le protégé de François
Mitterrand
ça ça me fait très plaisir parce que la
campagne avec laquelle monsieur tapis
est venu pensant qu'il pouvait acheter
Marseille un coin de Marseille oui
vous ne savez rien faire d'autre que ça
parlait blablater
à Paris
la politesse de laisser parler les
autres
ce soir là à gauche dans le propre camp
de tapis on se réjouit aussi de la
défaite du Parisien je suis pas
mécontent
c'était ouf quand même parce que c'était
une déferlante tapissile avait s'il
avait gagné à ce moment-là il gagnait
les municipales
au lendemain de l'élection tapis et tort
de lui il s'aperçoit qu'à droite comme à
gauche tous les moyens ont été utilisés
pour le faire perdre même les plus
illégaux
[Musique]
voilà tout simplement parce qu'il y a à
droite et à gauche on ne veut pas de la
présence de tapis à Marseille parce que
il le considère comme un intrus
cette enquête du Conseil constitutionnel
va confirmer l'existence de fraude lors
de cette élection
des irrégularités et des vis de forme
ont bien été constatés à l'encontre de
Bernard Tapie
et ses ennemis n'ont pas les inné sur
les moyens pour l'empêcher de gagner
333 fausses procurations ont été
établies par des électeurs fantômes et
comme si ça ne suffisait pas une
mallette pleine de bulletins en faveur
de tapis aurait mystérieusement disparu
résultat le Conseil constitutionnel
annule l'élection et organise un nouveau
vote quelques mois plus tard
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
suite à ce nouveau scrutin face à Guitet
tapis est officiellement élu député des
Bouches-du-Rhône
je vous avais promis qu'on a gagné on a
gagné
maintenant expliquez-moi comment il
pourra en gagner une puisque là où
c'était l'heure propriétaire ils n'ont
pas été capable de nous battre
quand vous reprenez son histoire
politique quand vous voyez comment il se
fait lire député dans les Bouches du
Rhône ce qu'il promet partout voter pour
moi vous aurez du boulot etc et
qu'est-ce qui se passe rien bien entendu
il en a rien à faire c'est un démagogue
quand il était député il faisait rien
c'est vrai que Bernard Tapie ne laissera
pas un souvenir inoubliable de sa
carrière de députée parce que ça
l'intéresse très modérément
tapis a fait son entrée au Parlement
mais c'est pas pour y travailler c'est
pour le symbole
mais le député tapis s'ennuie en
politique
les bandeaux l'Assemblée nationale lui
paraissent finalement beaucoup moins
excitant que le sport ou les affaires
l'industriel perd peu à peu son appétit
politique
[Musique]
jusqu'à ce qu'une émission de télévision
sur TF1 Vienne réveiller son ambition de
gravir beaucoup plus haut les marches du
pouvoir
ce 8 décembre 1989 Bernard Tapie est le
seul homme politique à avoir accepté
d'affronter Jean-Marie Le Pen sur le
plateau de Patrick Poivre d'Arvor c'est
la première fois qu'ils vont se
retrouver face à face tous les deux face
à face Jean-Marie Le Pen qui nous a dit
oui et Bernard Tapie qui nous a dit oui
on a eu une cascade de refus on lui
d'abord une un refus de la part du
gouvernement un refus de la part du PS
un refus de la part en fait en coulisse
c'est François Mitterrand en personne
qui a exigé que ce soit tapis et pas un
autre qui affronte Le Pen ce soir là
c'est la mise sur orbite de tapis en
propulse Bernard Tapie qui va apporter
du renouveau chez ses vieux socialistes
Kakashi on lance un nouveau produit
très vite le débat sur l'immigration se
transforme en un règlement de compte
entre les deux hommes
oui monsieur tapis est beaucoup plus
connu comme organisateur de spectacle
sportifs que comme député à l'Assemblée
nationale mais Dieu merci comme il le
dit il est dans la majorité
présidentielle et fier de bien vu de
l'Élysée château vous êtes à hâbleur
vous êtes notamment vous êtes un
Tartarin un bluffeur voilà la vérité et
vous nous attendons encore de voir à
part quelques jeunes hématopées que vous
lancez de temps en temps sur les écrans
ce que vous êtes capable de faire dans
la politique mais tapis ne se laisse pas
impressionner il connaît bien son
adversaire et il est décidé à lui rendre
coup pour coup quand il a une émission
importante les 15 jours avant l'émission
il ne fait que ça se préparer à
l'émission Bernard et on croit qu'il est
comme ça qu'il improvise pas du tout
c'est un énorme travailleur et il existe
ces formules il se prépare et il arrive
comme un boxeur sur le ring c'est pas
parce que vous avez une grande gueule et
vous criez fort que vous arrivez
la seule différence c'est que c'est pas
parce que vous affirmez fort quelque
chose que ce que vous dites est vrai
parce que vous dites n'importe quoi il
lui a dit tu me fais pas peur il en
avait voyez ce que je veux dire cette
expression est horrible je ne devrais
pas l'employer moi si distinguer il en
avait il habite à eau pratiquement au
premier round mais physiquement parce
que le panne n'avait peur et il m'a dit
je voyais en face de moi Le Pen
transpirant s'imaginant que j'allais lui
en mettre une et s'il avait dérapé il en
aurait pris une j'en donne qui me fait
pas peur aussi je suis un ancien
officier de parachutiste de la Légion
étrangère donc c'est pas un homme comme
tapis qui me fait peur bon je vais me
rappeler que j'étais un poids lourd
[Musique]
je lui rentre dedans le soir où ils
disent qu'il a dit tapis aux allées là
où peu d'hommes politiques aurait osé
s'aventurer il joue sur le même terrain
que son adversaire la provocation les
mots cinglants et surtout une présence
physique impressionnante
parce que vous avez vos gardes du corps
là non moi je rigolo enfin regardez vous
filmez alors regardez bien un peu ce que
c'est la question poids lourd deuxième
chose deuxième chose vous avez dit tout
à l'heure monsieur
[Musique]
la France découvre un politicien
instinctif capable d'en découdre avec le
président du Front national
tapis le député de Marseille vient de
gagner ses galons de leader politique
d'envergure nationale
voilà un nouveau personnage qui entre en
politique une sorte de héros positif de
la gauche qui va venir porter des coups
à l'extrême droite et donc évidemment
oui pour lui c'est en tout cas dès le
début une très bonne opération
médiatique je suis effectivement le
celui qui qui sait combattre le dragon
c'est un merveilleux coup c'est un
magnifique coup
juste après l'émission Mitterrand
téléphone à son poulain on ne m'épate
pas souvent en politique lui à outils
mais pour ce que vous venez de faire
chapeau
les Français aussi sont conquis un sur
deux déclare qu'il pourrait voter
Bernard Tapie à la présidentielle
l'émission politique l'heure de vérité
s'intéresse alors au phénomène
[Musique]
vous êtes arrivé d'évoquer une
candidature présidentielle oui ou non je
suis content là je vais prendre 5
minutes
c'est 5 minutes de trop une minute et
puis je vous donne on a le temps un peu
il y a votre patron de chaîne là tout ça
on peut faire 5 minutes de plus je vais
vous dire
si quelque part moi qui ne connaît pas
tapis je suis à Bayonne je suis cadre
supérieur et je lis les journaux et je
connais tapis par ce biais là je vous
faire une confidence il me sortirait par
les narines
d'abord parce que je trouve qu'il en
fait des tonnes ça c'est ce qui m'avait
semblé après ce que je veux dire je me
dis ce type il pourrait peut-être en
faire un peu moins que ça serait pas mal
alors si moi je suis à Bayonne je vois
quand je prends mon avion pour aller à
New York le sondage l'événement du Jeudi
5 pages en nouvelle-z cette espèce de en
première page comme ça avec bon mais
ce qui m'intéresse à voir c'est un juste
un point précis c'est est-ce qu'à un
moment ou un autre vous envisageriez et
pour quelle raison d'être candidat à
l'élection présidentielle moi j'ai
montré que j'étais démerdes que je
pouvais faire de chômeurs je pouvais en
faire des jeunes qui avaient un boulot
j'ai montré et je vais montrer qu'on
peut réduire le peine à moins de 10%
vous allez voir j'ai pas montré que
j'étais capable de connaître les
mécanismes de l'État j'ai pas montré que
j'étais capable d'être un bon ministre
j'ai pas montré tout ça après on verra
tapis président l'idée n'est pas pour
lui déplaire mais pour le moment il a
d'autres chats à fouetter le businessman
qui saute sur tout ce qui bouge à
flairer un très bon coup et un mois à
peine après cette émission il va
réaliser la plus belle affaire de sa
carrière
Adidas décidément sous les feux de
l'actualité comme l'ont dit puisque
cette firme allemande numéro un mondiale
des articles de sport est officiellement
passé cette semaine sous contrôle de
Bernard Tapie finance qui a racheté 80%
des actions au terme de 9 mois d'une
difficile négociation le ballon adidas
celui de la Coupe du monde dans les
filets de Bernard Tapie qui d'abord elle
correspond bien à ce que j'aime c'est
une mauvaise société qui fait du sport
et elle est très politique c'est une
démarche qui est beaucoup plus stratégie
politique à l'échelle mondiale que que
quand je vends des piles Bernard Tapie
il scénarise donc il choisit d'annoncer
le jour de la finale de la Coupe du
monde de football 1990 que il a réussi
un coup fantastique mais il ne dit pas
moi il dit la France c'est à dire que
c'est moi Bernard Tapie qui réalise
cette affaire mais c'est une affaire qui
fait la fierté de la France
un joli coup médiatique mais en réalité
un coup de bluff tapis n'a pas les
moyens de s'offrir Adidas il doit
trouver au plus vite
244 millions d'euros pour financer son
projet et donc pour que l'affaire puisse
se réaliser maintenant qu'il l'a annoncé
et maintenant qu'il l'a mise en quelque
sorte au service de la France et bien de
façon tout à fait logique le
gouvernement va se mobiliser au
gouvernement Bernard Tapie a un ami en
tout cas une relation proche et ancienne
qui s'appelle Pierre Bérégovoy ça tombe
bien Pierre Bérégovoy est ministre de
l'économie et des finances
tapis hébergovoit se connaissent bien il
y a quelques années l'homme d'affaires a
racheté l'entreprise look située à
Nevers le fief de Bérégovoy
[Musique]
lorsque tapis va racheter Adidas Pierre
Bérégovoy est ministre des Finances bien
placé pour lui donner un coup de main
grâce à son soutien les banques
publiques acceptent de financer le
projet du businessman d'accord et elle
lui signe un très gros chèque
Bernard Tapie absorbe ainsi une
multinationale 15 fois plus grosse que
sa propre entreprise
dans la vie ordinaire des affaires un
banquier quand il voit un de ses clients
qui lui dit j'aimerais archer une
entreprise qu'elle soit plus grosse que
la mienne et j'ai pas un sous à mettre
dedans même pas 5% pour la racheter
banquier vous moquez de moi non là on
lui a dit à pas ça le Lyonnais dira
banco allons-y honnêtement dans la vie
des affaires on n'a jamais vu un deal
pareil et c'est un cadeau des
socialistes à l'époque
est-ce un cadeau empoisonné Bernard
Tapie est désormais à la tête d'un
empire qui vend des articles de sport
dans le monde entier mais qui est en
mauvaise santé
Adidas et dans le rouge depuis des
années
mais pour sa première visite au siège
français de la marque en Alsace tapis se
pose en chef de guerre industrielle sûr
de redresser l'entreprise
les pertes cette année 90 seront 0
Adidas perdra pas l'argent 90 c'est
absolument certain et non seulement
perdra pas l'argent en 90 mais elle en
gagné beaucoup en 91 ça aussi c'est
aussi sûr pronostiquer pas de fermeture
il y en a pas de prévu pas de
déménagement il y a pas de prévu et pas
de vente de filiales il y en a pas de
prévu hein donc pour l'instant il y a
rien de tout ça il y a pas de
catastrophe en vue quoi on ne peut que
voir les choses positivement on oublie
quelque peu la personnalité on voit le
grand coup et on parle de nous alors là
ça nous a tous fait du bien oui il
comprend notre notre problématique il
est dans le monde du sport il est avec
l'Olympique de Marseille il a fait quand
même sa forme de choses on se dit ah
allez
mets tapis ne tient pas ses promesses et
il se produit tout le contraire de ce
qu'il avait annoncé plusieurs plans
sociaux
des centaines de licenciements
et il délocalise
[Musique]
sera totalement arrêté donc il y aura
233 suppressions d'emplois Adidas ne
veut plus de vous il faut donc trouver
des compensations mais ce tapis c'est un
bon parleur c'est c'est un beau parleur
et il passe par les bandes il veut les
sous et quand les sourds il les a il est
sauvé parce que partout oui où il passe
ça te passe
deux ans après l'arrivée de tapis aux
commandes de nombreux salariés ne font
plus du tout confiance en l'homme
d'affaires c'est un opportuniste donc
c'est un homme qui fait des coups et il
a fait un coup de communication et
Adidas est-elle prétexte à cette
communication pour servir ses intérêts
ça a toujours été ça monsieur tapis tout
ce qu'il a fait il a fait pour servir
ses intérêts
il n'a jamais été chef d'entreprise il
le sera jamais il était homme politique
soi-disant propriétaire d'Adidas il
connaissait pas du tout son sujet
en deux ans tapis n'est pas parvenu à
redresser Adidas et il semble déjà prêt
à quitter le navire
il n'a pas les succès qu'il espérait à
la tête d'Adidas il est dans une sorte
de de fuite en avant et donc cette fuite
en avant le conduit à accélérer le tempo
sur la politique
Bernard Tapie fonctionne à l'instinct
les affaires vont mal ils rebondit sur
la politique et il n'a pas à chercher
bien loin le Parti socialiste dirigé par
Pierre Mauroy a besoin de lui à nouveau
à Marseille pour les régionales cette
fois-ci
les élections s'annoncent difficile pour
le PS Pierre Mauroy pense que tapis peut
faire la différence il le nomme tête de
liste le président de l'OM pour être un
bon candidat pour la région
c'est région que nous devons regagner
[Musique]
tapissez que cette élection peut être
une marche vers le pouvoir il va tout
faire pour battre à droite Jean-Claude
Gaudin le favori et un candidat qu'il
connaît bien
Jean-Marie Le Pen
il va d'ailleurs faire toute sa campagne
sur un thème qui lui a bien réussi
jusque là
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
parce que les électeurs ils souffrent
mais comment peut-on tenir des discours
pareil c'est parce qu'on déculpabilise
ceux qui se trouvent une bonne raison
qu'on a un Front national si fort car si
le père est un ce qui vote pour
eux sont des salons
la phrase fait scandale et les médias ne
perdent pas une miette de la campagne de
tapis chaque jour interpellé par des
électeurs du Front national mécontents
pourquoi vous m'avez traité de
mais non
c'est vrai j'aurais pas dû non mais je
veux
pas par contre alors parce que je suis
pas là
justement pour vous faire réagir
[Musique]
tapis fait une campagne remarquable mais
les Français vont adresser un message
aux socialistes au pouvoir depuis 11 ans
en votant massivement contre la gauche
tapis empathie la région de Marseille
lui échappe au profit de son adversaire
de droite
[Musique]
président du conseil régional Provence
alpes-côtes Azur
[Applaudissements]
Bernard Tapie et battu mais ses efforts
vont être récompensés
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
une semaine après la débâcle régional
Mitterrand et contrat au remaniement il
faut du sang neuf chez les socialistes
et Bernard Tapie a beaucoup impressionné
le président lors de ses élections
il le catapulte ministre de la Ville
dans le gouvernement de Pierre bergovoy
age
[Musique]
il fallait trouver quelqu'un capable
dans des banlieues dans des quartiers
d'avoir un langage et un instinct
totalement compréhensible par un
électorat et ça évidemment il trouvait
pas ça au Conseil d'État ou à la Cour
des comptes tout ça n'est que quelques
politiques chez Mitterrand à la muse
non ça m'amuse c'est le
c'est le c'est une vision de
l'anthropologue qui qui voit marcher des
fourmis et qui dit tiens ah c'est pas
mal si jamais une goutte de vinaigre et
qu'est-ce que ça donne et je crois que
c'était plutôt ça
tapis est toujours le grand patron
d'Adidas mais il n'hésite pas une
seconde à endosser aussi le costume de
ministre
il n'a jamais été aussi heureux de sa
vie
sale Bété en transe c'était un truc
fantastique pour lui et si vous voulez
dans la catégorie bonbon c'est le plus
gros des bonbons et dès le lendemain
nous sommes allés au ministère un samedi
le ministère était fermé naturellement
et nous avons visité le ministère et on
a commencé à faire des projets
effectivement sur sur ce qu'on allait ce
qu'il allait faire de son ministère
mais l'enthousiasme de Bernard Tapie est
loin d'être partagé par les autres
ministres pour la plupart tapis est un
homme d'affaires sulfureux dont
l'éthique et la morale n'ont rien à
faire dans un gouvernement socialiste
ça a été les polémiques incessants sur
le mélange des genres entre ministre et
homme d'affaires il y a une question
d'éthique politique qui fait que on ne
peut pas être un très grand chef
d'entreprise et être ministre du
gouvernement a fortiori dans un
gouvernement socialiste est évident qu'à
toute une partie de la gauche qui est
offusqué choqué moi je me rappelle très
bien Lionel Jospin il était
scandalisé en fait Lionel Jospin Pierre
Mauroy
il y avait
Guigou ce qu'on pourrait considérer
comme les socialistes purs sucres
trouvaient qu'en effet il faisait tâche
dans le tableau
mais tapis n'est pas du genre à faire
profil bas et dès sa première
intervention en conseil des ministres
son attitude dérange
[Musique]
on conseille des ministres il faut bien
comprendre que c'est pas c'est pas un
endroit de débat du tout on n'est pas là
pour parler pour étaler sa science si
j'ose dire on n'est pas là pour faire le
malin lui faisait le malin il était un
des plus populaires de France
il envahissait la pièce vous savez
c'est un moment très attendu tapis doit
exposer son plan pour la ville selon le
protocole il est censé lire en deux
minutes les notes de ses collaborateurs
et passer son tour mes tapis veut se
faire remarquer et face à ses collègues
médusés il monopolise la parole pendant
de longues minutes
il a parlé trop longuement mais il a
bien parlé et donc je l'ai félicité mais
je lui ai dit tu t'es fait beaucoup
d'ennemis je pense que son attitude
n'était pas une attitude habituelle et
donc il a dû en agacer plus d'un il
dérangeait et en plus si vous voulez
comme Mitterrand l'appréciait il
dérangeait encore davantage c'est aussi
comme ça qui a commencé à s'attacher la
haine
des socialistes n'oublions jamais que
c'est son camp qu'il a tué que c'est son
camp qui est allé les chercher des
noises que c'est son camp qui la
maltraitée
si à gauche on déplore la nomination de
tapis à droite c'est une aubaine pour
les députés de l'opposition ils vont
utiliser sa réputation d'hommes
d'affaires sulfureux pour déstabiliser
Pierre Bérégovoy dès son premier
discours à l'Assemblée nationale la
France
souffre d'avoir 900
000 chômeurs de longue durée elle
souffre enfin du règne de l'argent fou
comme si tout s'achetait pourvu qu'on y
mette le prix
chômage
insécurité
corruption
voilà
tapis n'est impliquée dans aucune
affaire mais la droite scande son nom
comme s'il était un symbole de la
corruption cette surprenante nomination
de Monsieur Tapie
elle est inexplicable sauf à vouloir
récompenser à récompenser pour services
rendus
mais quelle curieux atlage monsieur le
Premier ministre que Monsieur Bérégovoy
la rigueur avec Monsieur tapis l'homme
de la ferrisme il faudra 15 jours vous
nous expliquer tout cela
tapis devait être un symbole d'ouverture
il devient l'emblème du mélange malsain
de la politique et des affaires Pierre
Bérégovoy est contraint de prendre
publiquement la défense de son ministre
on a enregistré vos déclarations
notamment lors de votre premier discours
à l'Assemblée nationale et l'emploi
d'ailleurs du mot corruption qui était
une nouveauté tout le monde s'est dit il
y a une contradiction qui arrive
aussitôt lorsque Bernard Tapie est
arrivé dans votre Gouverneur
ou un corrompu non mais il est clair que
personnellement ce n'est pas le problème
mais simplement objectivement Bernard
Tapie a soulevé un tollé dans
l'opposition mais Bernard Tapie est dans
mon gouvernement je considère qu'il est
honnête je considère que c'est un
gagneur je lui fais confiance
le Premier ministre droit dans ses
bottes parvient à éteindre la polémique
quelques jours plus tard les socialistes
respirent le gouvernement est même
plébiscité dans les sondages ça n'était
pas arrivé depuis des mois
mais une nouvelle affaire tapis va
remettre le feu aux poudres
le cou est porté par le député RPR
Georges Tranchant ce dernier accuse
Bernard Tapie de l'avoir arnaqué
lorsqu'ils étaient associés en affaires
c'est le début de la faire Toshiba
les deux hommes sont propriétaires
depuis 1982 d'une société de matériel
électronique na vs qui sommeille depuis
des années récemment tapis parvient à la
revendre au japonais Toshiba pour la
somme d'un million 800.000 francs du
moins c'est ce qu'il raconte à son
associé belle vente un million 8 amitié
Bernard mais tranchant vient d'apprendre
que tapis aurait en fait encaissé 13
millions presque dix fois plus
qui a été à Tokyo avec le président de
la société et il a négocié une indemnité
de 13 millions et c'est dit puisque
tranchant est d'accord pour améliori
j'en ai obtenu 13 le mieux va serait
quand même pas normal qu'il les touche
quand on a une conversation avec lui et
dit ben écoute t'as pas beaucoup le
temps de t'occuper de cette affaire et
tout tu es débordé t'inquiète pas tu es
mon ami tu es mon frère elle aimait la
main sur l'épaule je vais régler tout ça
je m'occupe de tes intérêts puis quand
vous avez passé la porte de son bureau
il dit à ses collaborateurs vous avez vu
ce couillon il me croit
quand tranchant s'aperçoit du pot rose
évidemment avec le RPR il voilà une
occasion rêvée de déstabiliser tapis
les socialistes François Mitterrand
puisque tapis apparaît quand même comme
le protégé de François Mitterrand à
l'époque donc je revois je revois tapis
et là je lui ai dit dis donc je voudrais
nettoyer cette affaire que tu as géré de
A jusqu'à Z et là il m'a dit
et là il m'a dit va te faire
il m'a dit nous sommes au pouvoir est
une pourra rien faire
en plus menacé mais Georges Tranchant
dit avoir des preuves et il porte
l'affaire en justice
tapis est lâcher le jour même par son
propre camp Pierre Mauroy qu'il avait
pourtant soutenu quelques mois
auparavant l'assassine en direct
la paix n'a jamais été ma tasse de thé
bon c'est tout c'est pas c'est pas issu
de cette c'est pas mais surtout je ne
souhaite pas que le parti s'ouvre
s'ouvre de cette manière là
tapis risque d'être inculpé pour
détournement de fonds
le soir même le ministre de la Ville en
poste depuis à peine de moi n'a plus
qu'une solution et elle est radicale
bonsoir l'information se bouscule ce
soir démission de Bernard Tapie du
gouvernement l'homme d'affaires
président de l'OM est convoqué la
semaine prochaine par un juge
d'instruction parisien pourra être
probablement inculpé dans l'affaire
Toshiba
c'est le coup de tonnerre dans le camp
socialiste et le premier choc d'une
longue série pour Bernard Tapie
c'est le sentiment d'injustice que je
ressentais qui était durable à digérer
le blessé en ce moment un
contestablement ça va un peu mieux ça a
été très dur
l'homme politique vient d'être torpillé
casse l'âne tienne le businessman
retourne à ses affaires tapis est encore
à la tête de l'empire Adidas qui l'a
racheté il y a deux ans mais la marque
est toujours en grande difficulté
ce 16 juin 1992 l'industriel est de
retour au siège en Alsace et devant des
salariés très inquiets il laisse
entendre que cette fois-ci il abandonne
la politique pour se consacrer à
l'entreprise
la condition elle est simple c'est un
engagement formel de ne plus les
pieds dans la politique pendant tout ce
temps là
j'ai fait un choix catastrophique ayant
d'un côté mes affaires de l'autre côté
la politique et j'ai fait un j'ai porté
un préjudice O2 soit disant il s'occupe
d'Adidas il est ministre il n'est plus
ministre il a des affaires sur le dos
alors où on va être nous on peut pas
croire à cet homme il ne nous a pas
convaincu au sortir de cette réunion où
il y a 80 personnes qui sont sous
pression et qui sont pris en découdre
avec lui et il sort de la salle pour
nous dire sont belles les Alsaciennes
évidemment ça fait son effet
l'homme d'affaires n'a pas convaincu par
les mots mais rares sont celles ce
jour-là qui résiste à son charme
[Musique]
c'est un homme de théâtre
mais l'entreprise Adidas c'est pas une
pièce de théâtre c'est pas un jeu on
joue pas
quelques jours plus tard le président de
la République en personne va confirmer
les doutes des salariés d'Adidas
François Mitterrand ne souhaite pas que
son poulain lâche la politique
c'est un homme tout à fait remarquable
dans le domaine qui lui a été confié je
n'attendais beaucoup d'ailleurs il n'est
pas dit que il ne sera pas en mesure de
reprendre les fonctions de ce type dès
lors que la justice sera mis au clair
cette affaire de caractère privé
en réalité dans l'affaire qui oppose
tapis à tranchant Mitterrand n'a pas
l'intention d'attendre la décision de la
justice en coulisse il œuvre même pour
que son ministre revienne au plus vite
au gouvernement
le président de la République m'a
téléphoné si un jour au bureau prendre
téléphone c'était
jamais
et donc j'ai réellement mes 30 au
téléphone qui me dit qu'est-ce que c'est
que cette affaire est-ce que c'est
commercial ah si oui c'est une
escroquerie commerciale mais c'est un
délit grave ah bon ah bon et Julie va
écouter puisque vous êtes proche de
Bernard Tapie
s'il me rembourse avec les intérêts et
avec un dédommagement moi je suis tout
prêt à retirer ma plainte
bon j'ai pas fait d'autres commentaires
auprès du brillant de la République
l'intervention du chef de l'État fait
peu de cas de l'indépendance de la
justice mais elle fonctionne à merveille
tapis accepte de rembourser tranchant
tranchant retire sa plainte l'avenir
politique de tapis s'éclaircit comme par
enchantement
[Musique]
Bernard Tapie revient au gouvernement il
avait un litige commercial avec un
député de l'opposition
la justice s'est prononcée
j'en ai tiré les conclusions que j'avais
annoncé je vous rappelle quand même que
personne m'avait obligé de partir quand
je suis parti et à l'époque j'avais dit
il me semble pas possible d'être à la
fois inculpé et ministre bon et j'avais
dit si je suis pas inculpé ou si je suis
plus inculpé envers la question et
maintenant je suis plus inculpé on a vu
la question 7 mois après sa démission
tapis retrouve son fauteuil de ministre
mais cette fois-ci il y a des conditions
il doit se retirer totalement des
affaires et revendre Adidas
Pierre Bérégovoy après l'affaire Toshiba
lui dit si tu veux revenir et tu
reviendras il lui promet qu'il reviendra
il faut que tu te débarrasses de ces
entreprises dans la précipitation il
veut redevenir ministre et dans la
précipitation il est tout s'échapper
Bernard aujourd'hui ça participation
dans Adidas pour un peu plus de 2
milliards de francs un groupe
d'investisseurs publics et privés il
avait acheté ses 80% de la grande marque
allemande pour un milliardet s'il y a
deux ans et demi
tapis vient de réaliser une belle
plus-value de 60 millions d'euros grâce
à la vente d'Adidas mais une fois encore
les banques publiques ont dû mettre la
main à la poche en rachetant elle-même
42% du capital d'Adidas
le Premier ministre est alors à nouveau
accusé d'avoir été trop généreux avec
l'homme d'affaires de la même façon que
Pierre Bérégovoy avait ordonné à des
sociétés publiques de participer autour
de tables de tapis pour acheter Adidas
et bien on va donner l'ordre au même
société de contribuer au débouclage de
l'opération autrement dit de racheter
l'entreprise pour le compte de tapis ce
sont des banques nationalisées qui
participent à un montage financier
au profit de quelqu'un qui est devenu
ministre et donc c'est vous voyez bien
la situation complet d'intérêt on a dans
un système
qui est incompatible avec une démocratie
normale
[Musique]
au lendemain de la vente d'Adidas à
droite l'opposition tir à boulet rouge
sur Bernard Tapie et ses amis au pouvoir
[Musique]
c'est pourtant un garçon pondéré il a
parlé lui hier soir je le cite de
pourriture de pourrissement de cancer de
gangrène écoutez les derniers arguments
ce soir de François Daubert je crois
vraiment tout permis je sais pas s'il
faut le dire au singulier pour Bernard
Tapie ou pour l'ensemble du gouvernement
mais cette espèce de sentiment
d'impunité absolument invraisemblable on
fait vraiment tout et n'importe quoi ça
relève des mêmes des mêmes réflexes que
ceux d'une république bananière ou on
abuse de l'état où on pile état et on se
sert abusivement des entreprises
publiques
le pouvoir a-t-il favorisé Bernard Tapie
en détournant des fonds publics le
président de la République est alors
sommet de s'expliquer
monsieur tapis ministre du gouvernement
actuel a récemment vendu à Didas a des
organismes dont l'État et le principal
actionnaire et qui sont donc proches du
pouvoir est-ce que cet événement nous
renvoie une image satisfaisante du
milieu des affaires comme Adidas a été
sous la conduite du ministre actuel
Bernard Tapie de grandes tempérament le
grand caractère naturellement objet de
lutte aussitôt on a dit pouvoir
profitent de ses amitiés il a obtenu des
faveurs et bien je dis non il n'y a pas
une faveur quant à moi j'ai appris cette
affaire en lisant le journal
Mitterrand parvient à éteindre
l'incendie mais la vente d'Adidas
tournera 20 ans plus tard au scandale
d'État
[Musique]
pour l'heure l'affaire porte un nouveau
coup à l'image des socialistes un mois
seulement avant les élections
législatives de 1993 c'est quand même
une époque terrible pour le socialisme
c'est le naufrage éthique le naufrage
moral il y a une odeur d'argent dans la
fin de ce conceptena à l'époque les
sociétés même s'engueulent entre eux en
disant n'a-t-on pas versé dans les
années fric et je pense que
tapis est quelque part le symbole de son
naufrage éthique de la gauche
les Français veulent-ils tourner la page
des années fric lors de ces élections
législatives il sanctionne en tout cas
très lourdement les socialistes au
pouvoir depuis 12 ans une gigantesque
vague bleue déferle alors sur la France
une très large victoire le parti de
Jacques Chirac compte 247 députés celui
de Valéry Giscard d'Estaing 213
l'ancienne majorité présidentielle et
laminée 70 députés dont 54 socialistes
jamais la gauche n'a connu des fêtes
aussi écrasante le désaveu est sans
appel pour François Mitterrand qui doit
se séparer du gouvernement Bérégovoy et
se résoudre à cohabiter avec un premier
ministre de droite ce sera Edouard
Balladur et pour la première fois dans
un gouvernement le jeune Nicolas Sarkozy
nommé ministre du Budget
[Musique]
après seulement 5 mois d'exercice tapis
lui doit déjà quitter ses fonctions il
n'est plus ministre et il n'est plus
homme d'affaires mais il n'a pas usé
toutes ses cartouches et Dieu sait qu'il
en a
tapis est plus que jamais le président
de l'OM avec qui il va remporter une
victoire historique
[Musique]
quelques semaines plus tard son Club
Olympique de Marseille remporte la Coupe
d'Europe une première pour un club
français
grâce à un but de la tête de Basile Boli
l'OM balle Milan AC 1-0 en finale de la
Ligue des Champions le président happy
était mur aux larmes
[Applaudissements]
dans cet état mais mais tant pis on va
pas faire semblant
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
Bernard Tapie n'est plus ministre depuis
deux mois mais grâce à cette victoire il
trouve une nouvelle occasion de
s'afficher aux côtés du Président de la
République
chacun l'ignore mais la retentissante à
faire
om Valenciennes et sur le point
d'éclater
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pour comprendre l'affaire il faut
revenir 4 jours avant la finale de Coupe
d'Europe
l'OM joue alors face au club de
Valenciennes
le maire de la ville Jean-Louis Borloo
est heureux de revoir son vieil ami
Bernard Tapie
mais à la mi-temps un défenseur de
Valenciennes affirme qu'un dirigeant de
l'OM attendé de l'acheter pour qu'il
lève le pied
il me propose une somme d'argent et
certains avantages si je laissais les
Marseillais passer aussi jouer pas sur
ma valeur quoi est-il vrai que cette
personne vous a proposé 200 000 francs
c'est exact l'OM aurait tenté de
corrompre plusieurs joueurs de
Valenciennes afin de ménager son équipe
quatre jours avant la grande finale en
Ligue des Champions
jusque là Bernard Tapie n'est pas
impliqué mais il va se jeter seul dans
la gueule du loup alors qu'il n'est pas
convoqué il demande à être reçu par le
procureur chargé de l'affaire
Eric de Montgolfier il veut le
convaincre que tout cela n'est qu'un
tissu de mensonge
tapis décide de se mettre au premier
rang ce qui est toujours une de ses
faiblesses il résiste pas occuper le
devant de la scène quand même il aurait
tout intérêt à rester en coulisse il
m'explique il va m'expliquer
vous connaissez rien monsieur lebroker
ça sent je vais vous expliquer et il
m'explique des choses intéressantes
d'ailleurs sans même bien se rendre
compte parce que c'est grâce à lui que
je comprendrais ensuite pourquoi il y
avait un intérêt à truquer ce match du
coup même si on n'avait pas franchement
pensé à lui là il a bien fallu se poser
la question
le procureur a un avantage sur tapis il
détient la preuve qu'il y a bien eu
corruption le jour même la police vient
de découvrir 38000 euros enterré chez la
tente d'un joueur de Valenciennes
tapis l'ignore et il continue de
pavoiser dans le bureau du procureur à
qui il rappelle qu'il est encore très
proche du pouvoir
m'explique
l'entrée de jeu je suis en retard
Monsieur le Procureur je sors de
l'Elysée avec le président de la
République et puis après il a embrayé
alors présenter quelques arguments sur
le thème Comment
Adam comme vous dans dans ce petit
parquet
méritait mieux que ça bon ça veut dire
soyez comprend aussi
puis vous verrez vous aurez mieux
après cette rencontre tapis devient plus
suspect que jamais aux yeux du procureur
la guerre est déclarée entre les deux
hommes qui vont s'affronter désormais
par caméra interposée j'ai cru
comprendre qu'il le souhaitait me donner
une information complète sur les mœurs
dans le football français et compléter
mon éducation d'apprentis footballeur
personne n'est lu consiste à la chasse à
tapis on veut ça j'ai cru entendre de
Monsieur tapis un appel clair à la
hiérarchie judiciaire pour museler le
procureur de la République
c'est dommage
ça prenne de la chasse à courre elle est
organisée mais avec un seul objectif tu
étais le pilon public je finis par la
connaître est extrêmement malléable
c'est souvent celui qui parle le plus
fort qui a raison surtout si on se tait
en face lui il y a l'air vraiment
frangeux je laisse faire ou pas
[Musique]
faut témoignages subornation de témoin
au fil des semaines les charges
s'accumulent contre tapis dont la mise
en examen semble inéluctable mais il
bénéficie d'un soutien inespéré
lors de la traditionnelle interview du
14 juillet François Mitterrand se lance
dans un long plaidoyer pour son ancien
ministre et en profite pour égratigner
le procureur de Valenciennes
il s'est révélé un excellent ministre
excellent ministre comme président de
l'OM il semble qu'il a bien réussi c'est
une énergie
l'intelligence et une énergie toute
personne qui n'a pas été reconnue
coupable par un tribunal ou par une cour
d'assis et présumé innocent
et si par quelques opérations que ce
soit on arrive à convaincre l'opinion
que cette innocent est déjà coupable
avant qu'il n'ait été reconnu dans les
formes légales commet une faute lourde
l'intervention du président n'y fera
rien
Bernard Tapie sera jugé deux ans plus
tard et condamné lourdement nous le
verrons
mais pourquoi Mitterrand s'implique-t-il
autant dans cette affaire ce petit
service n’est en fait pas désintéressé
en échange tapis va devenir l'instrument
du président qui a besoin de lui pour
éliminer son rival historique Michel
Rocard
[Musique]
sa façon de voir la politique
Michel Rocard a de bonnes chances de
conquérir l'Élysée dans deux ans mais
Mitterrand ne veut pas de lui comme
successeur et il a un plan pour
l'abattre dès les prochaines européennes
ou recaré la tête de liste du PS son
plan s'appelle Bernard Tapie
il encourage tapis à monter une liste
aux élections européennes et de ce point
de vue là François Mitterrand a tout à
fait utilisé Bernard Tapie comme cheval
de Troie pour affaiblir Michel Rocard ça
c'est très clair tapis est plein de sang
encore plein de de de verve d'envie
tapis le missile antirocar parfait
empêtré dans l'affaire om Valenciennes
tapis est prêt à tout pour s'attirer les
faveurs du président il accepte donc de
présenter sa propre liste aux
Européennes face à celle de Michel
Rocard
et afin de lui dérober un maximum de
voix le poulain de l'Élysée n'hésite pas
à frapper très fort sur son adversaire
qui veut être un jour président de la
République il va falloir qu'il comprenne
que pour être à gauche faut être à
gauche pour l'annoncer
faut le dire il faut le clamer ça se
mérite ça se décrète pas
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
la stratégie de Mitterrand a fonctionné
mieux que prévu la liste de tapis
obtient 12% des suffrages très affaibli
Rokar fait à peine deux points de plus
le rival du président et le grand
perdant de l'élection son rêve de
conquérir l'Élysée et ce jour-là anéanti
la mort politique de Rocard elle date de
ce moment-là et Rocard après a dit j'ai
été tué par un screen qui s'appelle
tapis
le missile tapis a bien atteint sa cible
et il n'est désormais plus du tout
indispensable pour le président
à partir du moment où il avait flingué
Rocard
sa valeur politique pour Mitterrand
était beaucoup moins grande et
d'ailleurs ces difficultés ont commencé
à s'aggraver à partir de ce moment-là
malgré ses bons et loyaux services
Bernard Tapie ne bénéficie plus du
soutien inconditionnel du pouvoir
cela tombe mal car au même moment il
doit faire face à une cascade record
d'ennui judiciaire et financier
[Musique]
le phocéan le 4 mars de 74 mètres le
Bernard Tapie et la cible de deux
procédures distinctes le Phocéen vote à
Bernard Tapie de mise en examen au même
moment l'une pour fraude fiscale
l'autre pour abus de biens sociaux
la juge d'instruction eva jolie ordonne
la garde à vue de Bernard Tapie qui une
fois de plus fait les gros titres des
journaux
c'est défendu le site bande d'enculés
police fascistes Anne batte je
me rappellerai de vos têtes pour tapis
toutes ces affaires sont destinées à
l'abattre politiquement
est-ce que pour vous c'est encore une
fois l'acharnement que vraiment c'est
souvent d'après vous
je sais pas s'il existe encore un seul
Français qui en doute
tous les jours il se passe quelque chose
et tous les jours quelque chose de pas
bien et de pas agréable et de
d'insuffables mais qu'est-ce qui va
encore arriver qu'est-ce qui va arriver
[Musique]
les affaires s'abattent sur Bernard
Tapie à une fréquence inouïe mais les
stockad qui va le mettre à terre et
porté par son banquier
le Crédit Lyonnais qui le soutenait
depuis des années est au bord de la
faillite son nouveau directeur Jean
perlevable tente de sauver ce qui peut
l'être et réclame à Bernard Tapie le
paiement immédiat de ses dettes envers
la banque
car l'homme d'affaires n'a toujours pas
fini de rembourser l'emprunt qui lui
avait permis d'acheter Adidas en 1990 et
il doit encore au Crédit Lyonnais 200
millions d'euros
le Crédit Lyonnais a demandé une saisie
conservatoire des biens du président de
l'OM les huissiers sont donc présentés
au domicile de Bernard Tapie le bras de
fer entre tapis et sa banque et
spectaculaire le Crédit Lyonnais fait
saisir les meubles de l'homme d'affaires
devant les journalistes qui n'en perdent
pas une miette
on s'est retrouvé avec son épouse on
était assis par assis par terre toutes
les deux avec lui parce qu'il y a plus
de meuble et
ici elle lui disait Dominique pourquoi
tu as fait de la politique et je lui
disais pareil j'étais Bernard pourquoi
avez-vous fait de la politique il a
vraiment signé son malheur le jour il
est en train politique
[Musique]
Bernard Tapie est au bord de la faillite
il n'a pas les moyens de rembourser les
200 millions d'euros qu'il doit au
Crédit Lyonnais tout le monde s'attend
alors à ce que le tribunal de commerce
prononce sa faillite personnelle
contre toute attente la Cour prend une
décision plutôt inespérée pour l'homme
d'affaires
curieusement au dernier moment sans que
personne ne s'y attende le tribunal de
commerce décide de lui offrir un répit
donc on donne à Bernard Tapie une
période de six mois au fond pour qu'il
ait une chance de se refaire en quelque
sorte on se dit mais pourquoi est-ce
qu'il est pas mis en faillite puisque le
Lyonnais a fait les comptes le passif
est toujours actif il faudrait les poser
le bilan et donc à ce moment-là on
comprend que
une instruction une pression une
recommandation a dû forcément être faite
au tribunal de commerce de Paris pour
offrir ce répit à Bernard Tapie
mais qui aurait donc intérêt à protéger
Bernard Tapie la presse soupçonne à
l'époque le Premier ministre Édouard
Balladur et son ministre du Budget
Nicolas Sarkozy d'être à l'origine de la
clémence du tribunal
il y a des échos de presse qui
paraissent un peu partout notamment dans
le monde qui disent mais c'est curieux
on a vu à plusieurs reprises le
président du tribunal de commerce qui
allait de Paris qui à l'époque
s'appelait monsieur Roger on le voit à
Matignon pas des potes portes des robes
mais pourquoi est-il reçu
selon les observateurs les démarches de
Matignon en faveur de tapis ne sauraient
pas désintéressé le Premier ministre
baladure aurait besoin de lui pour
remporter la présidentielle qui a lieu
dans quelques mois
et donc il y a des contacts secrets qui
sont très intéressants et Nicolas
Sarkozy lui-même qui rencontre d'un
tapis
la presse rapporte que lors de ces
rendez-vous tapis aurait accepté de
changer secrètement de camp
il serait prêt à être candidat à la
présidentielle pour affaiblir à gauche
le plus sérieux concurrent de baladure
Jacques Delors
on va bientôt rentrer dans une commune
présidentielle avec Édouard Balladur qui
a des très grandes ambitions face à son
ami de 30 ans Jacques Chirac mais il a
une inquiétude en fait qui est
l'hypothèse de l'or si Jacques Delors se
présente il a peur que de l'heure lui
mange l'espace politique la droite se
dit mais si de l'or à quelqu'un en face
de lui à gauche et si tapis était
scandina un tapis qui va affaiblir de
l'or c'est du bon pain pour nous quels
étaient les intérêts mutuels je suis la
torpille de l'or
et la contrepartie c'est quoi une
protection
tapis protégé par la droite à des fins
électorales Sarkozy et Balladur démente
catégoriquement cette version des faits
c'est du napurdité extraordinaire c'est
vraiment marche sur la tête si on en est
à dire des choses pareilles vraiment ça
prouve que la campagne électorale est
commencée qu'elle va voler très bas si
ça continue comme ça alors il faudrait
vraiment que je sois un personnage
totalement absurde pour mettre comporté
comme on le prétend cette c'est
invraisemblable pas une seule procédure
n'a été ni freinée ni accéléré depuis
que ce ministre du Budget que ça plaise
ou non je continuerai ainsi et tant
qu'on amènera pas un fait
montrant que j'ai freiné une procédure
je traiterai ceci comme on traite le
grand guignol
le ministre du budget ni tout
intervention de sa part en faveur de
Bernard Tapie
pourtant à la même période il aurait
tenté de convaincre Jean perlevade le
patron du Crédit Lyonnais de cesser les
hostilités envers l'homme d'affaires
c'est en tout cas ce qu'affirme Jean
perlevade 20 ans plus tard
l'entourage de Monsieur Balladur Nicolas
Bazire Nicolas Sarkozy qui apparemment
avait l'intention d'utiliser monsieur
tapis contre une éventuelle candidature
de Monsieur Jacques Delors à l'élection
présidentielle on me demandant pourquoi
faites-vous des ennuis à ce pauvre
monsieur Bernard Tapie
six mois avant la présidentielle Bernard
Tapie semble donc bénéficier du soutien
de l'équipe d'Edouard Balladur
[Musique]
mais leur alliance secrète va voler en
éclat le jour où Jacques Delort crée la
surprise sur le plateau d'Anne Sinclair
je vous repose ma question du début de
l'émission est-ce que vous êtes oui ou
non candidat à l'élection présidentielle
j'ai décidé de ne pas être candidat à la
présidence de la République
comme de l'or pour des raisons qu'elle
aura pas revenir renonce à se présenter
Bernard Tapie il sert plus à rien
[Musique]
est-ce le hasard du calendrier dès le
lendemain de l'annonce de Delore le fils
que réclame à Bernard Tapie 23 millions
d'euros d'arrière et d'impôts
coïncidence encore le surlendemain c'est
le coup de grâce le tribunal de commerce
annule le sursis de 6 mois qui lui avait
pourtant accordé quelques jours plus tôt
estimant que Bernard Tapie n'a pas les
moyens de rembourser le crédit lyonnais
il décide finalement de le mettre en
faillite tapis ruiné et inéligible
pendant 5 ans c'est le point de départ
d'une très longue traversée du désert
[Musique]
tapis n'a plus aucun soutien politique
et ses ennuis judiciaires ont fini par
le rattraper
accusé de corruption et de subordination
de témoin dans l'affaire du match truqué
OM - Valenciennes il va devoir affronter
la prison
le procureur de Montgolfier a requis 6
mois de prison ferme
[Musique]
en appel l'ancien ministre est condamné
à une peine de 8 mois de détention
[Musique]
je suis pas sûr que l'effet justifiait
la peine ferme
pas je vous le dis avec leur cul bannir
emblématique parce que c'était un
personnage emblématique pour le symbole
oui mais
je suis pas sûr aujourd'hui que je le
referai
[Musique]
après 165 jours de détention Bernard
Tapie sort de prison très éprouvé
il est libre mais il est inéligible et
il n'a pas le droit de faire des
affaires ni d'exercer une fonction dans
le football
la star des chutes des années 80 doit
repartir de zéro
[Musique]
après deux années d'une lente
reconstruction le voilà animateur radio
[Musique]
11 Bernards je te signale c'est nul ici
hein il y a rien
de toute façon allez essuie
bonjour pendant les années 80
vous vous situez vous intimement par
rapport à ces deux extrémités
[Musique]
que ceux qui m'aiment bien le disait
aussi
pour faire oublier sa réputation de
magouilleur tapis se reconvertit en
faisant ce qui lui a toujours réussi
dans la vie le comédien
[Musique]
et voilà et là c'est fini là il y a plus
de
plus de baratin faut y aller voilà son
rêve voyez c'est de me frapper c'est de
faire du mal
fini la politique fini les affaires le
nouveau tapis est désormais un acteur et
un chanteur qui Antonne gentiment ces
beau la vie en cœur avec Doc Gynéco
alors dis-moi ce match entre la
vendu le tu rigoles je les aime la
Valentine il arrive sur la planète Terre
dans le foot les affaires le rap les
ministère c'est toujours le gangster il
contrôle l'affaire
tout le monde pense à cette époque que
l'odeur de la poudre est derrière lui
mes tapis à une obsession récupérer sa
fortune subtiliser selon lui par le
Crédit Lyonnais
humilié ils ont fait déménager ma maison
avec des caméras de télévision dans la
cour ils ont fait visiter ma maison par
2000 personnes et m'ont mis en
liquidation des biens pendant ce
temps-là il faisait fortune sur mon dos
pour comprendre la guerre qui oppose
tapis au Crédit Lyonnais il faut
remonter à 1992
devenu ministre l'homme d'affaires
charge sa banque de revendra Adidas pour
lui au prix de 300 millions d'euros
tapis pense avoir fait un bon coup mais
il va découvrir que c'est sa banque qui
a fait une bonne affaire car elle a en
fait revendu Adidas non pas 300 mais
presque 700 millions d'euros dans son
dos tapis va tout faire pour récupérer
les 400 millions d'euros qui lui manque
il décide donc d'attaquer le Crédit
Lyonnais mais la justice est lente et
incertaine alors tapis aurait tenté en
même temps de négocier son dossier
directement avec le pouvoir
et les invites à déjeuner certains
cèdent certains acceptent ces
invitations déjeuner dans des
restaurants luxueux c'est la force de
Bernard Tapie pugna s'intrusif vous
ouvre un peu la porte email le pied
dedans il l'a fait chez Dominique
Strauss-Kahn quand Dominique
Strauss-Kahn était mise des finances il
l'a fait ensuite chez Laurent Fabius
quand Laurent Fabius succède à Dominique
Strauss-Kahn il le fait ensuite avec
Thierry Breton et à chaque fois il a le
sentiment que il est à deux doigts d'y
arriver
[Musique]
après cinq années de siège et 3
ministres assaillis sans succès
l'arrivée d'un nouveau patron à Bercy
redonne un tapis de sérieuses raisons
d'espérer
Nicolas Sarkozy vient d'arriver au
finance et il n'est pas opposé à l'idée
de régler son affaire à l'amiable
un médiateur est désigné et une somme de
50 millions d'euros et même envisagés
mais ce n'est pas suffisant pour tapis
qui quitte la table des négociations
il a refusé cette médiation parce qu'en
effet ça aurait éponger ses dettes mais
il n'aurait pas pu empocher un sous et
c'était pour lui il acceptable son
dossier est au point mort mais pour la
première fois l'état est allé dans son
sens et il le doit à Nicolas Sarkozy
pour comprendre ce qui lit les deux
hommes revenons 20 ans en arrière
[Musique]
Nicolas Sarkozy est alors le jeune et
ambitieux maire de Neuilly-sur-Seine et
Bernard Tapie l'homme d'affaires
brillant à qui tout réussi
les deux hommes se rencontrent à Neuilly
dans l'appartement du publicitaire
Jacques Séguéla et entre les deux hommes
le courant passe très vite
tapis déménage plusieurs de ses sociétés
à Neuilly mais aussi à Levallois dans la
ville du grand ami de Sarkozy Patrick
Balkany c'est un petit monde enfin on se
voit quand il y a des cérémonies à la
mairie ils sont invités quand il y a des
remises de médailles on s'invite à dîner
un petit monde de politiques de
milliardaires et de grands patrons
l'alchimie idéale pour faire des
affaires
tapis va par exemple racheter les piles
vont d'air avec le numéro 1 du bâtiment
Francis Bouygues dont le fils Martin est
très proche de Nicolas Sarkozy
20 ans plus tard les liens entre tapis
et Sarkozy sont encore solides tapis n'a
pas obtenu ce qui l'espérait du ministre
des finances mais il repart à l'abordage
avec un nouvel espoir
[Musique]
tapis a des raisons d'espérer car un an
plus tôt la justice lui a donné raison
contre le Crédit Lyonnais mais la
décision a été annulée en cassation et
Bernard Tapie n'a toujours pas récupéré
son argent désormais il souhaite que son
affaire soit réglé par un arbitrage un
tribunal privé dont le recours peut être
décidé au sommet de l'État tapis va
maintenant consacrer toute son énergie à
tenter de décrocher cette arbitrage
Nicolas Sarkozy est alors ministre de
l'Intérieur et le grand favori dans la
campagne présidentielle qui oppose à
Ségolène Royal
[Applaudissements]
un mois avant le second tour tapis
annonce sa préférence dans la presse
et il fait un choix qui déconcerte tous
ceux qui voyaient encore en lui un homme
de gauche
je n'arrive pas à savoir où veut aller
Ségolène Royal elle manque d'expérience
[Musique]
aujourd'hui il n'y a pas photo Sarkozy à
mes faveur
[Musique]
c'est son intérêt parce qu'il s'est
entendu avec Sarkozy c'était ils savent
que leur intérêt commun et voilà
tapis parce qu'il a besoin de son
arbitrage Sarkozy parce qu'il a besoin
d'être élu il applique la célèbre de
vise toujours du côté du manche parce
que c'est là où on pourra peut-être
avoir un peu de blé comme on dit dans le
milieu voilà je crois que c'est faut pas
aller plus loin
tapis ne recul devant rien pour plaire à
Nicolas Sarkozy un mois avant l'élection
il l'aide à rencontrer son ami Bernard
Kouchner qui à l'époque joue dans le
camp adverse chez Ségolène Royal
le président Sarkozy et c'est d'avoir
quelques prises de guerre comme on les
appelle pour montrer que il fait un
gouvernement beaucoup plus large y
compris avec des gens qui ont servi à
gauche et donc tapis est trop ravi de
rendre ce service là donc c'est lui qui
appelle Kouchner et donc il y a
finalement un petit déjeuner qui a lieu
au ministère de l'Intérieur à l'époque
où Nicolas Sarkozy ministre d'intérieur
ou tapis amène Kouchner et c'est tapis
qui servent entremetteur à l'époque où
Kouchner et l'un des porte-paroles la
campagne de saganem Royal donc voilà ils
organisent la trahison et le l'ultérieur
ralliement de Kouchner Sarkozy
Sarkozy vient de réaliser une conquête
précieuse grâce à tapis un service qui
serait totalement désintéressé selon
Bernard Kouchner
il a pas été payé pour ça c'est parce
qu'il pense que ce serait pas mal parce
que l'ouverture se fera faut demander ça
à un tapis pas à moi vous dites
imaginer quoi qu'il a été payé par la
part le pardon par l'arbitrage
il a pas besoin de moi mais vous me
prêter une influence considérable que je
n'ai pas c'est ridicule pas du tout
énorme de vous
téléphoner tout seul voyons
certes la décision de régler son affaire
par un arbitrage n'est toujours pas
d'actualité mais tous les efforts de
Bernard Tapie vont peut-être finir par
payer
[Musique]
le 6 mai 2016 Nicolas Sarkozy était élu
président de la République
après la guerre de tranchées Bernard
Tapie peut passer à l'offensive
à peine Nicolas Sarkozy est élu qui fait
le forcing
for signalée il va voir tout le temps
plusieurs de vos collègues journalistes
étaient suffoqués en allant à l'Élysée
de tomber nez à nez avec Bernard Tapie
sortant qui du bureau de Pérols qui d'un
autre conseiller voir du bureau du
président puisque effectivement il a vu
le président et il n'allait pas voir le
président uniquement sur des affaires
politiques
en un peu plus d'un an Bernard Tapie se
rend 22 fois à l'Élysée
selon l'agenda présidentielle il
rencontre quatre fois en tête à tête le
chef de l'État
les autres rendez-vous ont lieu avec les
proches du président
principalement avec son secrétaire
général Claude Guéant
là comme bien d'autres maintenant ça me
gêne pas qu'il voit Sarkozy moi je l'ai
vu beaucoup plus que ça me faut dire que
j'étais son ministre enfin bon très bien
j'ai il y a plein de gens qui a réalisé
beaucoup plus que Bernard Tapie et je
vous signale que Bernard Tapie il allait
à l'Elysée sous François Mitterrand de
la même façon il a une séduction
formidable imaginez la pression qu'il a
mis sur tout le monde avant l'arbitrage
je suis persuadé que les types des
cabinets voyaient où les ministres ils
avaient une pression maximale de tapis
il leur vendait attendez moi je suis
l'ami du président donc déconnez pas là
voilà ça il sait le faire à merveille
le dossier de Bernard Tapie se promène
donc à l'Elysée avant de resurgir au
ministère des Finances et ce grâce à un
coup de pouce du ministre de l'écologie
Jean-Louis Borloo son vieil ami
c'est lui qui aurait contacté
personnellement le cabinet de la
ministre Christine Lagarde pour que la
demande d'arbitrage de tapis soit
examinée avec la plus grande attention
lui était favorable à l'arbitrage mais
il a décidé de rien d'ailleurs vous ne
trouverez pas une pièce signée de
Jean-Luc Borloo
après 14 années de procédure entre tapis
et le Crédit Lyonnais les efforts de
l'homme d'affaires finissent par payer
trois arbitres sont nommés et une
décision qui va faire du bruit et rendu
le 24 juillet 2008
[Musique]
pour la ministre de l'économie
l'arbitrage était la solution la plus
rapide pour en finir avec cette affaire
mais surtout selon elle la moins
coûteuse
on était en présence de douzaine de
procédures qui duraient depuis plus de
15 ans qui véritablement coûtait une
hémorragie d'honoraire à l'état plus de
10 millions d'euros ont déjà été
consacrés à la défense dans ses affaires
tapis rien à un moment où il faut savoir
aussi tourner la page à condition que ce
soit de bonne condition on veut en finir
avec ces histoires des années qu'on a
appelé les années les années fric de la
période Mitterrand ce soir on entend des
personnalités aux parties socialistes
parler de copinage d'État est-ce que ce
soir vous pouvez affirmer que Nicolas
Sarkozy n'est pas intervenu dans ce
dossier est-ce que vous croyez que j'ai
une tête à être copine avec Bernard
Tapie point numéro 1 et est-ce que vous
pensez que j'ai reçu des instructions
pour protéger non il est inimaginable
que la ministre de l'économie et des
finances et pris cette décision sans
avoir une injonction du sommet c'est
c'est purement et simplement impossible
la décision a été prise par le Président
de la République donc je pense que il y
a dans une république des principes qui
doivent être respectés et dans cette
affaire ils n'ont pas été respectées et
qu'on a utilisé l'argent public dans des
petits arrangements on se plaint en
disant mais c'est quand même bizarre
mais c'est tapis a gagné oui il a gagné
parce que le dossier est bon point vous
dites il y a pas eu d'intervention
extérieure et quelle intervention
pourquoi vous pensez que le président de
la Bully qui appelle les arbitres les
juges enfin c'est ridicule vous avez vu
la qualité des juges
mais la somme colossale attribuait à
Bernard Tapie ne passe pas et un mois et
demi à peine après la décision des
arbitres Bernard Tapie et sommet de
répondre aux attaques de parlementaires
sans triste et socialistes parmi
lesquels François Bayrou François
Hollande et Jérôme Cahuzac il conteste
l'arbitrage et soupçonne l'homme
d'affaires d'avoir bénéficié des faveurs
du pouvoir
pourquoi y a-t-il eu
une procédure d'arbitrage alors que la
justice suivant son cours les parties
les ayant saisi il était possible de
trouver une issue moi je peux vous dire
que à aucun moment aucun aucun
strictement aucun moment on peut voir la
main du pouvoir actuel dans la décision
de faire l'arbitrage mais à aucun moment
l'homme d'affaires défend point par
point son dossier mais après trois
heures de face à face avec les
parlementaires
l'émotion va prendre le dessus des
Arbites je crois largement aussi
crédible que vous êtes largement aussi
honnête que vous êtes ont décidé de
modéliser
et lorsque j'arrive avec un jour un
homme se fait traiter de tapis breton
en Bretagne parce que devenu une injure
publique vous peut-être vous mesurez pas
qu'elle est l'énormité du problème mais
je souhaite pas de porter un seul jour
un nom qui devient une injure publique
c'est comme si je m'appelais
pourri ordure même si j'ai fait défauts
et j'en ai fait je mérite pas du tout ce
traitement et encore moins par la banque
qui a gagné de l'argent sur mon dos je
vous souhaite un seul jour de vivre ça
une seule fois je vous souhaite de vivre
ça oui ça va je vous souhaite un seul
jour d'être insulté comme ça pendant des
années une menace prémonitoire Jérôme
Cahuzac sera lui aussi quelques années
plus tard mais les a une affaire d'État
en fin de séance Bernard Tapie est
interrogé sur la façon dont il compte
dépenser ces millions et il s'engage
solennellement les Arbites ils ont donné
ce qu'ils ont voulu donner ils l'ont
estimé à ce prix là
ce qui contrat c'est ce que j'en ferai
ce qui contraste c'est ce que j'en
ferais en tout cas je peux vous dire
aujourd'hui rappelez-vous ce que je vous
dis ça sera pas pour acheter le
phocéanie pour acheter le limpide de
Marseille et je ferai ce que je pense
que ma conscience m'en donnera de faire
voilà
la suite de l'histoire montre que
Bernard Tapie va tenir sa promesse
[Musique]
il n'achètera ni l'OM ni le Phocéa en
revanche il va acquérir un yacht de 76
mètres
à 40 millions d'euros
il va aussi s'offrir une villa de 500
mètres carrés sur la Côte d'Azur pour 47
millions d'euros
et il investit également dans un groupe
de presse pour 51 millions d'euros
dès qu'il a eu les ronds vous avez vu
qu'il s'est payé le bateau à Saint-Pons
le machin etc non mais il est fou il est
fou mais pourquoi a-t-il cette soif
c'est inadmissible ce qu'il a fait si
vous prenez l'argent public si vous
prenez l'argent des Français au moment
où il se cercle la ceinture et que vous
prenez cet argent pour autre chose alors
que vous avez prétendu faire de la
politique que de faire du bien aux
Français vous êtes un monstre vous êtes
foutu de leur gueule et vous signez que
vous êtes foutu de leur gueule il a
signé qui s'était foutu de la gueule des
Français
[Musique]
cinq ans après la décision des arbitres
des zones d'ombre plane toujours sur
cette affaire
la justice a ouvert plusieurs enquêtes
et l'arbitrage a fini par devenir un
scandale d'État
s'il s'avère que l'arbitrage rendu en
votre faveur dans le dossier Adidas
Crédit Lyonnais est entaché de
favoritisme ça va contribuer très
largement au dégoût des Français pour la
politique laissez-moi vous expliquer une
fois pour qu'un arbitrage soit bidon il
faut qu'il y ait dans le cou la ministre
tous les fonctionnaires Bercy les quatre
arbitres ou trois arbitres les 6 avocats
qui est capable de faire ça
expliquez-moi qui est capable de faire
ça je vais vous dire à faire de cette
affaire je vais vous dire ce que c'est
la
aire socialiste qui va chez Monsieur
Nadal qui va chez vous regardez ce que
c'est tout ça je vous demande socialiste
et uniquement les sociaux
tapis ne cesse de le répéter selon lui
l'affaire est instrumentalisée par les
socialistes qui seraient prêts à tout
pour avoir sa peau
[Musique]
coïncidence ou pas il a fallu attendre
que François hollande soit élu pour que
l'État se décide à réclamer à l'homme
d'affaires le remboursement des 405
millions d'euros
les juges quant à eux soupçonnent tapis
son avocat et l'un des trois arbitres
d'avoir truqué l'arbitrage ils sont tous
mis en examen pour escroquerie en bande
organisée
[Musique]
face à l'ampleur de la polémique Bernard
Tapie a écrit un livre pour donner sa
version des faits ces derniers mots sont
une ultime promesse
je ne ferai plus jamais de politique
[Musique]